the world where God demands that you
constantly humble yourself in front of
what's happening to you you know right
now there's fires in the Smoke well
guess what everybody in Washington DC
New York City has to deal with that
reality has imposed itself you have to
you have to humble yourself before
what's happening around you and make
adjustments accordingly you don't get to
just assert well I think the world
should be this way I think God should
honor my sacrifices yeah right I think I
should have the tower however it is no
if your sacrifices aren't being honored
the first question to ask is what have
you done wrong
[Music]
thank you
hello everyone watching and listening
today I'm speaking with author
mathematician and political commentator
Dr James Lindsey we discuss Marxism how
it evolved from a singular ideology into
a Genus spawning many oppressor slash
oppressed dogmas across modern culture
ideas such as Equity critical race
Theory queer Theory we Trace these
sub-marxus doctrines back past
fundamental narrative into the
theological realm and detailed their
utility in what would you say justifying
the acquisition of power we also
discussed the grievance studies Affair
of which Dr Lindsay was a co-author so
James I kind of feel like I know you I
follow you on Twitter and watch all the
trouble you cause or some of it anyways
and we did do a podcast a number of
years ago with Helen and Peter and uh
but I actually don't know you and so
let's start with that I'd like to know a
little bit more about you and let's let
everybody who's watching and listening
know too so
um let's say what what are what are you
when you're not causing trouble on
Twitter what are you involved in at them
what is your what does your actual life
look like it's causing trouble on the
road
yeah well I mean Twitter overlaps with
the road because it lives in my pocket
so you know that's convenient but
I do a lot of speaking I speak a lot
I've had the privilege this year of
getting to speak all over the world I
get to speak at the EU Parliament that
was great um right right right and
because it's really funny everybody's
telling me that and I think it's true
this is the best public speech you've
ever given public and so what you know
what a setting did hit the one
congratulations on that front well it
turns out that the night before it's a
silly story the night before I had a
smaller meeting in a restaurant with a
number of the MEPS from different
countries and I'm trying to talk and I
tend to be humorous and speak quickly
and this is just my style and that all
my jokes were Landing flat and I got
kind of awkward and I realized it's they
don't speak English English is not even
you know they're not even all you know
rough on the joke front so then I had to
start slowing down and I kept really
conscious of slowing down and
enunciating and and trying to use
simpler terminology to talk about you
know neo-marxism and post-modernism it's
very difficult so I gave this speech and
it just happened to work out but I've
had this privilege so you know know 175
flights I took last year to give you a
feel for how much on the road there is
getting around meeting mostly with
Grassroots organizations some bigger
political stuff or legislators but
mostly
moms and dads that are trying to do
something in this country and around
other like Canada as well to try to
change are you mostly in North America
when you're traveling overwhelmingly
just in the U.S uh-huh overwhelmingly
how did the EU invitation come about
they reached out to me so I'm not
exactly sure how they they got connected
with me but one of the MEPS they put
together a conference uh at the EU
Parliament to talk about was that in
Brussels it wasn't Brussels yes it was
in their terrible building in Brussels I
was it was very important yeah a huge
airport would you've been yeah so you
know the ultimate Tower of Babel so
there's that Park back behind it that
has the ostriches you know about these
statues so there's a small Park it's you
know not very big however many square
meters very small grassy area and
there's all these strange statues and
you come on and you say three-legged
statues it looks like aliens and you get
closer and you realize they're all
ostriches with their heads stuck in the
ground and I thought how poetic is this
building oh yeah you know uh and it but
yeah it was in Brussels and so how were
you received there well it was a
conservative group it was a center-right
European party called identity democracy
foundation so they were very warm to me
I actually had a handful of uh there was
a student group from the foundation that
was also present at the EU at the same
time and so many of them came maybe over
a hundred of them came right and so I I
got a lot of feedback actually they sent
me messages as one does on Instagram or
whatever and said you know this was
amazing yeah they you use speech kind of
went viral didn't it it did yeah it
really took off it actually it kind of
lurked for a month and then it exploded
about a month later and it's still just
going crazy right now and so you said
you slowed down and you enunciated more
carefully and but what do you think you
what do you think you hit on that that
made it so attractive as a speech well I
was the question of the the whole
conference which is a three you know
three meeting session that I was at the
first one it was what is woke and what
does it mean for Europe and so I tried
to give in a sense of genealogy of woke
and actually a taxonomy is more accurate
I started off by saying well I think
that woke is in fact Marxism that's
evolved to attack the west and the
techniques it's using are reminiscent of
Mao's Cultural Revolution and so you can
say that it's Marxist or malist but then
I said we can't understand that unless
we understand Marxism in a bigger way if
we focus on his economic analysis and
capital we miss the entire picture if we
take a step back and say that he
outlined an entire theory of man and the
world and our behavior in it and the
meaning of life and purpose Talos for
for our being which is to transform the
world into the Socialist
Utopia to advance history to its
intended end then you can see that the
particular mode of analysis becomes
fungible if it's economic analysis for
Marx then you get classical Marxism if
it's race analysis for the critical race
theorists it's almost you have to
massage around the edges but it's almost
the exact same Market well that's
certainly what it seemed to me to be you
know one of the things that's been
disturbing I suppose on the gaslighting
front is whenever I draw a relationship
between post-modernism and neo-marxism
first of all people say two things that
I don't know what I'm talking about
which by the way is rarely the case and
second that you know that's that's a
conspiratorial misreading of the
relationship that there's nothing that
most post-modernism has nothing to do
with Marxism and you know I've taken
that criticism seriously because it
happens a lot I think well you know is
there some manner in which I have this
wrong and then I go back as much as I
can to the source documents including
Foucault and I think and Dara and I
think
well they said they were marxists that
seems like you know proof and uh the
entire intellectual milieu at that time
in France was marxistent including
people who should have known better like
Jean-Paul Sartre so it's like that was
the that was the water in which which
those particular fish swam and the
postmodernists
when they themselves say that their what
would you say that their intellectual
effort is tending in the Marxist
direction or as an extension of Marxism
I'm pretty much inclined to believe them
and so I don't understand how this
notion that those two
two concepts are separate
has come about you do you have any any
idea about that I do I've thought
tremendously on this question and I
believe I have an answer and kind of
like yourself if I open my mouth usually
I've thought about something before I I
spout off and in this case
it's the nature of the way these
theories evolve they evolve through what
technically is called dialectical
critique and so each descendant Theory
say if we use Marxism as as the common
ancestor if you and that's what I did by
the way in the EU as I said it's think
of Marxism as a genus and then you have
all these species well post-modernism is
a species but they evolve through
dialectical critique so for each new
derivative that comes out say
postmodernism
they have to create themselves by giving
a critique of the thing that they were
before so they start by saying here's
where Marxism is wrong and academics
hyper focus on these distinctions and
they say look I see they said that's
what you think they say just like you
say well they say that they're marxists
that looks like proof they say well they
said we're criticizing Marx so that's
proof that they're different in the
neo-marxists are no exception and you'll
find I literally you think it's a
narcissism of small differences
yeah so there's a level of analysis at
which these I think your genus and
species uh metaphor is a good one so
there's a there's a level of analysis at
which these are all variations on a
theme and there's another level of
analysis where the well no they're
distinctly different which is exactly
what does happen in academic
microarguments right so you think part
of that's well I think part of it's just
the attempt to sow confusion as well oh
probably so or and then also ignorance
on the part of the critics because they
just don't know enough about what
they're talking about to even know that
there's a relationship between
post-modernism and new Marxism and
Marxism I guess the other issue too is
that in principle the
post-modernists were skeptical of meta
narratives and it does seem not
unreasonable to point out that Marxism
is a grand meta-narrative yeah so if
you're skeptical about metanarratives
you know you might start out by being
skeptical about Marxism and if you just
focused on them post-modern critique of
meta-narrative then you'd say Well it
couldn't be allied with Marxism because
Marxism is a meta narrative but my
response to that would be what makes you
think that incoherence ever bothered a
post-modernist right right in fact they
specialize in incoherence and and and I
think because it can sow Discord and
Chaos most effectively this is why this
this metaphor the genus species is so
important and for me this you know well
Marxism is a grand meta narrative et
cetera this is almost like saying
imagine that the the animal clade that
we're talking about is something to do
with cats right and so now we have cats
tigers well tigers have a tail right and
in
lions and lions have a tail and house
cats house cats have a tail so cats have
tails right well not Bobcats not lynxes
right and so if we think of the tail as
being a grand meta-narrative in fact the
broad historicism of of classical
Marxism you find both neo-marxism or
critical Marxism and post-modernism are
becoming skeptical of this kind of grand
uh trajectory of History narrative that
was kind of the early modern thought and
as we shift from Modern thinking to
post-modern thinking away from the
scientific and into the kind of
blatantly mystical and romantic which
the post-modernists are wholly
characterized by you can just imagine it
it's a cat without a tail yeah yeah I
see if we do this you know I said
Marxism is economic and critical race
theory is race and we can see the queer
theory is the concept of who defines
what's normal post-modernism is really a
Marxist analysis of who gets to say what
things mean yeah
it seems to me the fundamental core
around which these Concepts circulate is
well well one core is resentment and
bitterness there's an Envy there's no
doubt about that on the motivational
front yes but the other core more
ideological and intellectual would be
the notion that every social interaction
is best viewed through the lens of
oppressor and oppressed and so then you
can do that with economics which is
essentially what Marx did but once
you've established that pattern well
it's all about victimization and power
so that I think I think it's actually
the same claim that that it's it's like
a neo-christian claim that emerged out
of the Middle Ages because there was a
Doctrine in the Middle Ages among some
strands of Christian thinkers that the
that the secular world the Earthly world
let's say was the domain of Satan
himself right it was ruled by the prince
of power and I think that's exactly what
the marxists claim except there you know
are they in favor of that or against it
it's very difficult to say but their
fundamental claim is something like all
human relationships can be understand
understood through the lens of power and
oppression I mean that's Foucault in a
nutshell right yeah his whole theory is
that everything is carceral power every
time I say that word I have to stop
intelligence it means prison yeah
incarcerated is the is the derivative
first yeah for people but
um it's all about carceral power so
these these sects that you're referring
to in the Middle Ages of kind of bizarre
Christianity were actually Gnostic
heresies that we're developing and I
think that actually by means of of
hegelth coming down through Marx who
inverted it yeah I believe we actually
actually are looking at agnostic heresy
inside of economics and social in fact
if we read phenomenology of spirit from
Hegel 1807 is a publication
you did distinctly the sense that what
he means by spirit is what he says he
means by spirit it's a spirit of society
it's a social phenomenon it's kind of
the the seed of uh of Sociology in a
sense and this
social spiritual realm is for for Hegel
quite literally because he was a
heretical theologian is the the working
of the holy spirit in the world it's not
this you know Transcendent uh person of
the godhead it is this
this is the functioning of human beings
in the collective
all and how that's moving through
history and so if we relocate as a
modern transformation of kind of this
heretical Christian middle age
Middle Ages you know almost New Age
movement of the time mystical movement
of the time we have a very clear shift
from the transcendental to the social to
the social Universe representing the
spirit and so then Marx
he actually figures out the code he says
no hegel's got it upside down we focus
on the idea and the state will follow
and the spirit will follow the state and
he said no no and then this the spirit
will will sublate and raise to alphaben
in German and raise to a higher level
and we'll have a new idea blah blah blah
that's his his Trinity cycle his
dialectical cycle for Hegel well Marx
says no it's upside down we start on the
ground we do the work we do the Praxis
we do the work as the modern phrasing we
do the Praxis we do the activism and we
change society directly and then that
will cause as Society changes the what
he called the inversion of Praxis the
social conditioning to rain down on
people and actually reify the
transformation of society so this I
think is where Marx had inverted Hegel
and this is where we have a shift from
the pre-modern transcendental spiritual
to the modern social spiritual and this
just becomes the playground of Romantics
and eventually The postmodernists Who
throw up their hands and say this whole
thing is just this you know gigantic
Dynamic of power to where if you and I
Converse I mean at one point I remember
maybe 10 years ago some feminists it
didn't go very far but they
posited this very post-modern argument
that there was no possibility ever for a
woman to consent to sex with a man
because there's always a patriarchal
power Dynamic so there's always no
matter what no matter how much you know
she says she's interested or whatever
there is always
always for being coerced
so this is I think you know kind of this
huge shift and you say you know
academics get mired in these micro
distinctions yeah and that is partly
their job so okay fine but it's also how
they carve out territory though that is
that there is an incentive structure
there yes but this is uh it's so
important to to realize that if we don't
take a step back and understand this
bigger picture that this is a
fundamentally theological architecture
I like knowing exactly where my meat
comes from and with moink I know it's
coming from small Family Farms all
across the country Mike delivers
grass-fed and grass-finished beef and
lamb pastured pork and chicken and
sustainable wild caught Alaskan salmon
straight to your door Mike lets you
choose the meat delivered in every box
select an existing box or create your
own set your delivery Cadence and enjoy
delicious meat you can cancel anytime
but you won't want to if you're not sure
where to start check out their standard
box it comes with a little bit of
everything chicken ribeye burgers and
steak moink is all about supporting the
Family Farm think about it this way two
percent of Americans are farmers but 100
of Americans eat we need to show our
support for the families that keep us
well fed after receiving my first moike
box I was floored the salmon and chicken
are both fantastic and the steak might
be the best I've ever had and keep in
mind I cooked it myself with a freezer
full of moike products I can without a
doubt say it is a fantastic deal on a
ton of delicious and well-produced
products you won't be disappointed and
you can rest assured all of Mike's Meat
comes from wholesome American farmers so
keep American farming Going Strong by
signing up at moinkbox.com jbp right now
in Dr Peterson's listeners can get free
bacon in your first box and let me say
it's the best bacon you'll ever taste I
re-upped my subscription because I ran
out too fast Mo ink box.com jbp that's
moinkbox.com jbp
well we could even go back farther than
that I think so would you tell me what
you think about this this current set of
ideas that I've been working on more
recently so
um I I mentioned earlier that you could
think about Marxism in two ways and the
new Marxist variants that we've been
talking about you can take you can think
about them as
um
expositors of the doctrine of power that
every social relationship between human
beings can be understood
as a function of domination and
compulsion so that would be marriage
that would be friendship family economic
relationships history itself every
single social relationship now that has
the advantage of extreme Simplicity and
so even if you're not very bright you
can understand it it's comprehensively
explanatory so that's attractive on a
psychological front and then there's a
nefarious element and the nefarious
element me is that well if it's all
about power
then not only am I thoroughly justified
in my use of power because after all
that's just what you're doing but it
also uh justifies any accusation
possible because you might come up with
a claim for example that you're a
proponent of free speech and I can
easily say well no like as a white
colonialist benefiting from the
privilege of your position you just use
the argument that such a thing as free
speech exists to justify your position
the power hierarchy right and that's a
universal criticism and so then I can
take anything that you might claim as
positive and just transform it with
intellectual Jiu Jitsu into a
manifestation of the power drive you
know and and it's fair to say
that the drive to power is a human
motivation but it's not the only it's
not the only one that's right and it's
also fair to say that
when social relations are corrupted they
become corrupted in the dis in the
direction of power but it's com that's a
completely 100 percent different
proposition than the claim that all
human social relationships are
predicated on power I mean you mean all
do you yeah okay so I know where okay so
so so there's the power claim but then
there's this undercurrent of bitterness
and resentment and I see this
system of ideas that's playing out as an
extension actually of the battle between
Cain and Abel yes because okay so why
yes
this bitterness this Envy there's the
the the you know the the very devout and
and or devout maybe is not the right
word but the very obedient
Abel and then he says these advantages
King gets very upset yes well that's and
comes to murder him this is exactly the
motivation and this is how do they
proceed you know so if we take seriously
the concept that this is a gnostic
heresy and you look back whether it's
Jews right if you come to that
conclusion that it was a gnostic heresy
because I I didn't know you had pursued
this all the way back into the religious
realm well I stumbled on a
recommendation uh onto a philosopher
named Eric foglin who's got quite the
reputation for having named Marx as a
gnostic and then I went down a rabbit
hole reading about gnosticism and
reading about
um Hegel and his relationship to this
kind of mystical reinterpretation of
Christianity you know Glenn Alexander
McGee air foglundies these analysis I
read a little bit of Evola not a big fan
of Julius evola's writing but I read a
little he makes these claims quite
strongly as well and uh then I just
started to read the Gnostic texts myself
and in the Hermetic texts and so I
Stumble I I mean I've been claiming for
a decade that this has a religious
phenomenon yeah yeah it is posing as
sociology and some phenomena in some
some fashion but
this is what really finally allowed me
to put it together and and it doesn't
matter gnosticism is by its nature
parasitical it's that we have discovered
through whatever means divine you know
Revelation whatever happens to be the
secret salvific knowledge that they
don't want you to know so there's some
higher truth
that's hidden and maybe there's a Code
written in the Bible that if you have
the secret means of divining it then you
can determine what the bible really
means and when you go and you talk to
the priest and the Priestess no that's a
heresy they turn around and say he just
doesn't want you to know that
which when you say it goes back to Cain
and Abel it goes back further than that
it goes back to the serpent and Eve God
hath not said you know you've got this
em emblem of of all authority that has
declared this thing then you have the
subversive element that comes in and say
was that really really sad so so it
seems to me that that this is a way of
conceptualizing the relationship between
the religious and the philosophical and
the sociological
so if you if you delve deeply enough
into the battle between two idea sets
and you keep going down as you go down
to more and more fundamental layers
you approach the religious because the
religious is by definition the most fun
and I'm offering a definition here that
religious is by definition the most
fundamental and so I think when you're
looking at something like the culture
War that's going on you can you can see
it as a battle between ideas but then
when you trace the ideas back you see it
as a battle between narratives and when
you trace the narratives back you see as
a battle between fundamental narratives
and as you approach the most fundamental
narrative you're trading on religious
grounds yeah so what happens in the
story of Cain and Abel of course is that
Cain makes second-rate sacrifices right
and he knows their second rate and
because of their second rate and he's
not all in
his sacrifices aren't accepted and
that's just a phenomenological truth
which is life is so difficult that
unless you make the proper sacrifices
you're not going to succeed and then
he calls God out on that says the cosmos
is constituted in an ill-gotten manner
because I'm not successful and God
basically says well if you did things
right things would work out for you and
instead of Cain accepting that as
corrective information his countenance
Falls so goes the story and he flies
into a murderous rage and destroys his
own ideal because he really wants to be
able right and then the descendants of
Cain become he's murderous Cain
obviously because he kills Abel and then
the descendants of Cain become genocidal
right so so and so the way the biblical
narrative essentially opens because Cain
and Abel are the first two real human
beings right because Adam and Eve are
made by God so the the biblical
narrative portrays the battle between
the spirit of Cain and Abel as the
fundamental battle that rages in the
human heart so it's the battle between
the spirit of proper sacrifice which is
what Abel represents the spirit of
improper sacrifice that's Cain and the
cascading consequences of improper
sacrifice and then a metaphysical battle
between those two spirits that
characterizes well that's when history
starts right so that's the central
battle in history and I think of Marxism
as I think the French Revolution was a
manifestation of the spirit of Cain and
that the them that Marxism itself is a
then the postmodern Enterprise that's
besetting us now another manifestation
of the spirit of Cain and it's the
proclamation I don't exactly understand
the relationship between that and the
claim that it's power that's the ruler
of all things but I do know that the
spirit of Cain is indistinguishable say
in the biblical Corpus from the spirit
of Satan and Satan is the the satanic
ruler is definitely the ruler that uses
power and compulsion and deception to
control everything I mean I think your
connection that you're looking for
um boils down I mean Foucault gives us
the hint right everything is a prison
this carceral power so what is power in
this analysis is the power to compel
right to extort to force behaviors to
paraphrase Larry Fink and so right no
kidding yeah paraphrase Larry thinking
and bloody Black Rock if we again if we
take this Gnostic concept seriously the
gnostics believe that there is an
all-good Transcendent God behind
everything that's so good that he's
completely pure Spirit completely
uncorruptable and therefore anything
material must not be of that it must be
in fact evil and so where did it come
from and they've got a mythology for it
but it doesn't matter this create this
character called the demiurge comes into
being through a series of kind of cosmic
accidents and the pleuroma as they call
this and the demiurge demiurge comes
from the Greek demi-orgos Demi ergos
means Artisan or Builder he's the
architect of the world so he builds out
the world but in fact he's a demon and
so he builds out the world as a prison
so God in Genesis in in Genesis 3 with
the fruit
has imprisoned Adam and Eve in the
garden and the snake is saying did you
know he just doesn't want you to know
that you're like him
this same system this is what Cain's
rejecting he's giving his second-rate
sacrifices he's not doing what he should
God's telling him if he does what he
should things will work out and he's
like no this system's corrupt right
exactly and so this is the same that
calls God out on his misbehavior
essentially that's right if you don't
think that's the sin of Pride there's
definitely something wrong with the way
that you're thinking right and so I
think that this is ultimately the
Gnostic motivation it must have been I
wonder if it's as surprising for you as
it is for me that this is the rabbit
hole that you've ended up going down you
know I have no idea when we started
investigating these theories that you
know that the root consequence of that
investigation would be to move down
levels of analysis into the religious
domain so I did start to understand that
as you move down levels of analysis you
inevitably end up in the religious
domain because the religious domain is
the deepest level of analysis right so
but it I mean has it surprised you that
that you're I'm sitting here talking
about gnosticism for example trying to
diagnose the ills of the modern world
yes it has surprised me and it's very
curious as well because I was this
character I had this it cuts through
every human heart soulchin very
eloquently put I was this character I
was a very frustrated academic and I
think it's typical what is the most
common I mean maybe there are others but
one of the more common psychiatric
disorders the academics complain about
is imposter syndrome right though I've
got this degree but if I'm actually
stupid because the PHD earning process
is quite difficult and you're always
surrounded by people who know far more
than you do who remind you of it on a
daily basis and so you end up with this
massive amount of imposters I'm not
really you know good at the thing I'm
not as good as they think I am this kind
of delusional complex and rather than
taking the certification and saying you
know well okay I've earned this
and so you have this Baseline where you
you like marks what do you do with your
time you dig into some area you finally
see the secret you know truth nobody
else saw within that I'm just talking as
an Impulse I'm not getting religious yet
and you see this and then you write and
you write and write and seven people
read it nobody cares and you start to
think to yourself why am I not getting
career advancement why am I not getting
the accolades why why isn't Society or
if you're marked why isn't everybody
else just paying my bills don't they see
how important my social theory that I'm
writing is so you're doing something
that's not particularly but it's Kane
this is a second Lucifer by the way it
is you're making a second-rate sacrifice
and expecting to get
first results and that jealousy grows
right there well yeah well that
intellectual pride is a big part of that
too you know I work so hard well it's
it's there's it's worse than that even
it's not even that I worked so hard like
I had clients for example now and then
who had a luciferian problem and they
were often very smart people who hadn't
put in the work that's certainly the
case but they were very annoyed because
it was clear to them that they were
smart as or smarter than everyone else
and yet the world hadn't unfolded at
their feet Yes you know and so they were
very bitter and resentful about that and
like it's definitely the case that in
Milton like Lucifer who's the bringer of
light is definitely an envious intellect
right yes and he's the the angel who in
God's Heavenly hierarchy Rose the
highest and fell the furthest and that's
definitely that's something that is
definitely something that can
characterize intellect because the human
intellect is a remarkable uh spirit you
might say capable of the greatest good
but it is also the thing that can fall
the farthest and that wounded intellect
is the most vicious of spirits and so
that's sort of that combination of Cain
and Lucifer and it's also you know it's
also the case in the biblical Corpus if
you take the stories apart that the
spirit that raises the Tower of Babel is
the Wounded Spirit of Lucifer and Cain
right and that's erecting a
technological alternative to God but
partly in an attempt to worship
intellect instead of well instead of
well instead of whatever God might be
the highest something like the highest
Spirit of genuine self-sacrifice right
something like that well the fact is
that the the wounded intellector the
wounded narcissist doesn't humiliate
itself in front of anything but the
world or God demands that you constantly
humble yourself in front of what's
happening to you you know right now you
get this weather thing or it's not
weather these fires in the Smoke well
guess what everybody in Washington DC
New York City has to deal with that real
reality has imposed itself the Smoky air
is here you don't have a choice about
whether it's here or not you have to you
have to humble yourself before what's
happening around you and make it
adjustments accordingly you don't get to
just assert well I think the world
should be this way I think God should
honor my sacrifices yeah right I think I
should have the tower however it is no
if your sacrifices aren't being honored
the first question to ask is what have
you done wrong yes right and that's more
or less by definition right because if
the this is also what what one of the
things I see problematic in the
so-called manosphere online it's because
all the men who are unsuccessful are
clattering on about what's wrong with
women it's like by definition there's
nothing wrong with women yeah right if
you're not adapting yourself to women
it's not the women's problem yeah right
what's your problem and that's by
definition and it's the same thing in
relationship to your relationship to the
world is that if your sacrifices aren't
being rewarded the right question to ask
is how am I prideful and blind not how
is the world constituted in
yes okay so now you said something
interesting biographical you just
touched on it sure oh but you said that
there was a time in your life where you
were bitter I think I've got that right
and feeling that you were marginalized
and that the world wasn't laying itself
at your feet as a consequence of your
sacrifices so tell me a little bit about
more more about that when that happened
and why do you think that the same thing
isn't true now or do you you know you
know what I mean because if something
like that has got you in its grip yeah
you think you've escaped from it but
that doesn't necessarily mean that you
no right right right right so so let's
go to like so how long ago was tell me a
little bit more about that how long ago
was that and what were you doing what
was your career at that point so this is
right after I left Academia which I
didn't get chased out there's a urban
legend online of course from the people
who hate me that I couldn't get a job
now I I took 100 of the job offers that
I applied for in other words zero okay
so so what what well what what was your
academic history well I had I got a
Bachelor's in physics and Masters in
math and I finished a PhD in math in
2010. it's a PhD in math yeah okay okay
so you were you were those are very
difficult disciplines right so if you
rank order disciplines by IQ math is
actually at the top it's hard I think
it's math first and then physics right
so you got a PhD in math yes okay so you
can clearly think on the quantitative
side of things yes so okay okay and so
then you decided not to apply for
academic jobs yes okay and so why did
you decide not to apply for academic
jobs so at the time the last so this is
two thousand maybe seven or eight I
don't remember which year was first the
last couple of years that I was doing my
PhD we had all these you know teaching
meetings or I don't want to say faculty
meetings because I was a grad student
but equivalent to a faculty meeting and
the new rule of the of the University
was fail the smallest number of kids
possible one per per course no more and
I'm thinking I teach math what
university University of Tennessee wow
that was actually a rule that was
established
mostly informally convention yes it was
it was we need to focus on student
retention don't alienate students with
bad grades that consumerist approach
correct yeah
bloody managerial speak and Unholy
wokism exactly then you have the
university the pastored child of the two
worst monsters you could possibly put
together so I didn't want to participate
in that so I chose not to apply for
academic jobs at all I didn't want to
participate if I can't teach where the
students who succeed get treated for
success and the students who fail fail
and have to try again or go somewhere
else or do something different I didn't
want to participate in that I I even you
know having come from physics I cared
very much if I certify somebody as being
competent in calculus and they go on in
an engineering program and they're not
competent in calculus I'm doing it
actually a grave evil and if the
university is telling me I have to do
this or show up and talk to the dean and
explain why I failed a third kid in the
class
I don't want to participate in this
system anymore so I just left
Elysium is dedicated to the biggest
challenge in health aging Elysium brings
the benefits of Aging research to
everyone they create Innovative Health
Products with clinically proven
ingredients Elysium works with leading
institutions like Oxford and Yale and
they have dozens of the world's best
scientists working with them eight of
them are Nobel Prize winners their
Flagship product basis is an NAD plus
supplement that has sold over three and
a half million bottles why NAD plus
studies suggest that any D plus levels
and healthy aging go hand in hand in
fact at a recent conference eight out of
10 doctors were taking an NAD plus
supplement we know there's no such thing
as an actual Fountain of Youth but Time
Magazine has said that NAD plus is the
closest we've ever gotten to one we've
got celebrities like Victoria Beckham on
our side and doctors like Richard D who
says I recommend it to all my patients
who are looking for something to improve
their overall long-term Health Richard D
also has his wife parents and children
taking basis as well basis has proven to
work in a is backed by clinical trials
so support energy production healthy
aging and feel good for your age with
basis as a special offer exclusive to Dr
Peterson's listeners go to trybases.com
Jordan and enter code Jordan at checkout
to save 25 off your first purchase of a
monthly plan restore youthful levels of
NAD plus now try basis.com Jordan okay
and so how have you kept body will go
how have you kept body and soul together
since then and because your career is
kind of mysterious and then also let's
go back to this issue of of bitterness
yes yes yes okay so after leaving the
university I just got I just got a job
actually I didn't I became a massage
therapist which is the internet thinks
this is just hilarious
um it's not a mysterious Story how or
why I have two components of this story
my wife is one so I had an into the
profession you know on a direct line
where I understood what it is and what
it does and secondly I had injured
myself doing Zoo early in my 20s and it
turned out that massage therapy was what
actually fixed it where all these
doctors I had seen weren't able to
figure out how to sort out that what I
had actually done is messed up my psoas
muscle and so the massage therapist was
able to massage the problem out of my
psoas and the subsequent problems out of
my lower back muscles and glutes and
thighs and it fixed it and I no longer
had you know these terrible episodes
lower back pain so I said I want to do
this for people
so let's go and so I started studying
simultaneously medical textbooks on
muscle pain and going to massage school
which is a little less rigorous and and
it did this for a number of years well
being academic I became a little
academically bored
this is a fine career and I enjoyed what
I did and was very helpful and rewarding
but I needed some academic stimulation
so I started to read philosophy of
science I started to get in discussion
forums online this is where I discovered
kind of the feminism you know explosion
that was kind of happening and blog blog
spaces all over the Internet and
everybody's getting accused of this and
I got involved in a little bit
regretfully now with a new atheism
movement
and got caught up in all of that for a
few years but the resentment I think
most of the new atheists actually regret
becoming involved yeah I think so I even
see Echoes of that at Dawkins now
because he's seen what sort of children
he produced right yeah very petulant
very uh very very not healthy yeah well
one of the things I learned from you was
Catholic was about as Satan as you get
right yeah so you destroyed that you
think well you think the Catholics are
insane you wait till you see what that's
protecting you from right
polytheistic paganism totally right oh
boy with some child sacrifice thrown in
and some nature worship right but of
course in in the woke era we live in now
we don't have as much you know these
pagan gods as they were construed in the
pre-modern we have power dynamics uh
racism systemic racism well the Irish
are going to sacrificed 200 000 cows to
Gaia yeah that's right no that's nature
worship that is exchange the weather to
change the weather it's really pretty
damn funny it is it's so it's so
appallingly comical that it's it's it is
definitely a form of cosmic joke
but we do need a few of those sometimes
yeah yeah yeah okay you started working
as a massage therapist this was around
2007 2008. what the hell did your wife
think you were doing oh she thought she
loved the idea that we were working
together yeah yeah boy that's quite the
detour out of the bathroom it was but
you know she's not of that world and so
she didn't really care one way or the
other if I stayed in it or not and uh so
she thought it was you know Noble that I
was picking up something different and
working with my hands and working with
people yeah and trying to to help people
with chronic pain that you know for
whatever how long did you practice as a
massage therapist I was licensed for 10
years so I probably practiced regularly
for about eight are you good at it were
you able to attack you can really get
good at yeah touch healing so
interesting my wife's a massage
therapist yeah it's so interesting to
see how much wisdom you have in your
fingers you know if you yeah if you if
you if you place your hands on people
you can feel weirdly enough where there
are whatever a knot is you know it must
be a place where circulation isn't
optimal or where the muscles have
tightened up for some reason but it's so
interesting that you can feel that out
and that you can fix it too yeah yeah I
was actually quite good at it and it was
pretty nice uh but again academic
boredom and so I think maybe just in
general that trying to get engaged in
these academic activities starting to
try to write books and trying to get you
know paid attention to it wasn't coming
where the world's not laying itself out
of my feet My Sacrifice isn't being
honored if you will but I got really
like I remember telling my wife a couple
times like I work so hard I know I'm
smart yeah why don't people recognize it
and it's so tempting to say Well it must
be something wrong you think that was
one of the things that tempted you into
the new atheist movement I think that
was generally frustration with growing
up largely a religious in the broadly
Southern Baptist south
okay I felt the new atheism movement was
like a breath of fresh air for me
because it was the first place I felt
that I had found in the world where I
could say what I thought without it you
know whatever long
set of problems it would create for me
you know everybody when I grew up in the
South well the thing about people like
Dawkins too and Harris for that matter
is they are characterized by a certain
Clarity of thinking right right and you
know I have some what would you say
sympathy certainly for for both Dawkins
and Harris I think they're both good
people in in some fundamental sense I
mean I know Harris was trying to ground
a transcendental ethic in what he
regarded as unshakable truth and he
thought the unshakable truth was
essentially objective reality and I also
have some sympathy for that perspective
because it's the post-modern critique of
that in part that's led us to where we
are right but uh but the problem is is
that well we can't go into that there's
lots of problems as hadn't you started
to stumble into that obviously looking
at the strange tangle of religious ideas
that have produced the conundrum that we
see before us okay so you were keeping
Body and Soul together you and your wife
by working on the massage front yeah you
said that you're that wasn't didn't
provide enough stimulation for your your
ravenous intellect and you weren't
getting a lot of purchase on that front
and that was making you bitter and so so
how did you can when did you realize
that what did you do about it what makes
you think you have done something about
it well I didn't realize it till after
the fact so that helps me think that
maybe I have done something about it
because it's one of these things I look
back at and I say wow I really was a
different person
and now what made you learn
getting beat up by life not physically
losing over and over and over again and
finally accepting that maybe I have to
do something different well that's
interesting eh because another thing
that can happen if you get beat up over
and over and again and lose is that you
can get more and more bitter well listen
you don't have to learn I had the same
lesson though I used to fight I used to
fight you know sport fight for real
fourth degree black belt all this stuff
back in when I was young uh I mean young
adult not a child not one of these
children black belts you know in my
early 20s in my mid-20s and um I fought
a lot and frankly sometimes I won but a
lot of times especially on the way up I
got my ass kicked right and you start
learning real fast that you can get as
mad as you want as somebody who can beat
you up and it doesn't let you they will
still beat you up they'll beat you up
worse yeah that's right it beats you up
much worse right right and that and
there's nothing to argue about on that
there's nothing there's no debate down
on the floor with your nose on the
ground that's right right that's right I
can't abstract yourself out of that but
I think the the kind of magic secret
sauce besides getting beat up with all
the repeated you know attempts and
failure attempt and failure was that I
actually just got really busy I didn't
have time to ruminate on this because I
picked up the grieving studies Affair
Peter and Helen and I started to yeah
that was all consuming I mean every
waking moment that I had for you want to
walk people through that a little bit
sure so Peter and I had this wild
brained idea to write as many fake
academic articles for feminist theory
gender studies you know all these kind
of woke post-modern journals that put
them in the highest ones we could get
and see how many we could get
uh published and we had planned roughly
two years our goal was that we were
going to start in in August of 2017
writing these things as fast as we could
write them and we were going to write
until sometime around a year later some
summer 2018 we would stop writing and
finish the academic process on wherever
we got and we'd see what happens so when
we wrote the 20th paper which we
finished in June of 2018 we called it no
more no more new ones let's just finish
these do what we have to do to get them
you know into the world and see where it
goes but then the the article got
published on us in in October so we
didn't see all the way to the end so we
wrote 20. six of them were a learning
process they're utter failures I think
they proved lots of interesting things
it's maybe a discussion for another day
but then when there are these 14 others
seven of those had been accepted seven
more were under peer review a
sociologist wrote an article I wish I
could remember who it was but soon after
this happened and he said that he
anticipated that either four or five of
those seven based on what the peer
review had said and the quality of them
four or five of those seven probably
would have been accepted as well but the
ones that wouldn't were also the
earliest among that batch of 14. she got
good at writing fake articles we cracked
the code and we at one point I wonder if
Chad GPT could do that yes no question
absolutely no question I'm 100 confident
that it could write papers and read them
we don't need the academics at all the
chat GPT can write them they can do it
don't read them that's right yeah and
grade them for that matter yeah yeah
yeah yeah so I uh
I this project just consumed my life you
know it's an academic article a new Full
you know 8 000 word fully cited academic
article we covered 15 sub-domains of
academic
Pursuit across the 20 papers so we're
all over the place having to read as
fast as we can read and write as fast as
we can write in kabulation together it
was all we did and so I couldn't think
plus I knew I was doing something
productive
and then of course why did you think it
was productive
we thought that you know once we started
to get success it was very clear that we
had figured something out that was
proved against the real world where I
mean academic peer review isn't exactly
the real world quality real world but it
is the system the the actual system
where the the real thing that certifies
knowledge or whatever we pretend this
this corrupt system does
where that is and we were we were we
were in we cracked the code we we said
at one point I said at one point
I am convinced now that I could have a
100 success right every paper I write I
can get in I can pick a topic write
whatever I want and I can get it in and
anything gentrification of cornbread was
the next one I had planned just
something ridiculous that right this was
a Humanities focus when you were doing
your PhD work well and the previous work
on that in in the stem fields
had you had any philosophical interest
or interest in the humanities at that
point or did this all develop after you
stopped pursuing them I mean very little
I took a philosophy class as an elective
as an undergraduate I had a tremendously
good time with it but that was it
um oh right so this really wasn't so hot
that's so interesting you hopped out of
that mathematical world into massage
therapy and into the humanities and to
the humanities yeah right and you were
really coming at it from from the
perspective of a stem mind you had a
stem mind right that's interesting you
know a lot of the greatest psychologists
in the early part of the 20th century
were engineers say they established all
the statistical techniques that all the
social scientists use right I'm an
interesting mathematician though A
different kind there's there are 13
different branches of mathematics and
what's called an enumerative
combinatoric combinator assist that's a
lot of syllables enumerative
combinatorics gives these very kind of
Baroque counting arguments and a common
Tauruses will be upset that I called it
baroque
all the rest of the mathematicians will
cheer that I said this that I've
confessed this but we give these things
that are called Counting arguments so
that we say that in an equation is true
and identity is true because both sides
of it count the same thing in two
different ways and so you describe it
counts on this side of the equation it
counts it this way on this side of the
equation it counts it that way a simple
example without doing a bunch of math is
that if you don't know that the the
square numbers 1 4 9 16. so on 25 the
square numbers obviously count the
number of squares in a square grid and
you know n by n
well it turns out that the square
numbers equal the sum of the first n odd
numbers so one then one plus three is
four one plus three plus five is nine
one plus three plus five to seven is
sixteen and on add 9 get 25 and you can
see how it goes but what that is is you
count the corner that's one then you
count the three that go around it that's
three more then you count one well it's
two by two so there's two then there's
two and there's one so that's going to
be the next odd number and then it's
three three and one so two threes and a
one oh the next odd number that's it
that's two different measurement
techniques would you say well yeah in a
sense in a sense it's because that's one
of the ways we triangulate on truth
right is we use multiple measurement
systems to to abstract out the same
pattern they call that construct
validation construct validation and
psychology well psychologists have have
tried to wrestle with the idea of how
you know when a concept is real right
and the reason they wrestled with that
was because of of the issue of diagnosis
like for example is anxiety and
depression are they the same thing are
they different right well they overlap
to something great and then when you're
starting to ask about what whether two
things are the same or different you're
asking about the nature of reality and
you're also asking about the nature of
measurement and what psychologists
concluded essentially was that to
establish something as real imagine
there's a pattern there you needed a set
of qualitatively different measurement
techniques all of which converged on
analysis of the same pattern it's what
your senses do right because your senses
provide five qualitatively distinctive
reports and if they converge you presume
it's like a definition of real five
converging reports using qualitatively
distinct measurement processes
constitutes reality yeah sure right
right so it seems to me there's an
analog there of the equation issue that
it's true if one counting method
produces this result and another
counting method produces this result
that constitutes an equation and those
two things are what would you say there
there's
things real there
that's a fair thing to say so okay well
anyway does the word equivalent right
yeah right equivalence relation right so
right so they're the same yeah yeah so
as it turns out this gave me a
tremendous amount of background there I
think how does math help what I do a lot
of background in detecting a pattern and
being able to articulate it
in a less abstract way as to what it is
so I go find I would find patterns and
say how can I describe this pattern not
just in one way but in two ways right
right at the same time and you were
doing that in the paper so I read the
papers and I detect a pattern of how
they use language and how they cite and
who they think are important and then I
just go reproduce this in another way
and of course I'm building a little chat
GPT in your imagination more or less yes
definitely absolutely and it was
extraordinarily successful another by
the way thing that math helps with is
mathematicians are pretty particular
about definitions yes the most right
because whatever we say is a definition
all of the logical conclusions of that
definition in the in the axiomatic
system are necessarily True by by
consequence forever universally right so
if you get it wrong a little bit if you
say for example a prime number is a
number that's uh divisible by one in
itself that's a very common you know
Elementary School definition uh that's
not adequate because it leaves open the
question is one prime and the answer to
that is no one is not a prime number
number
so the actual definition of prime when
you get very cautious is it is a number
with exactly two factors
which sounds like the same thing but
it's not the same thing because it
removes that one question of ambiguity
upon which all expressions of things
like the functions right well so okay so
partly what you're doing as you're
diving into the underlying religious
substrate is to go farther and farther
down into the axioms well yes but it
also I have the ability to read them and
when they misuse words
I can figure out what they must mean by
the word they're using and then I can go
start to check that to see right right
and when like equity for example like
Equity or diversity or democracy or
actually literally almost every word or
power yeah and so oppression yeah yeah
it's really useful to fight figure out
what those words mean so that stem mind
ends up having been it was trained in
kind of these two particular skills and
I think I had a proclivity there was
definitely why does anybody become a
kind of Fringe branch of mathematics
where it's hard to get a job if you
apply for them because there's just not
that many of them why would you do that
is because you have a proclivity for it
there's a selection bias into that
you're interested in it you're good at
it
I thought it was the most fun thing in
mathematics I could have been an
algebraist I was good at algebra algebra
is very employable it's very necessary
it's very useful
I didn't want to be an algebraist I
wanted to be a combinatorist which why
because I really enjoyed it I really
enjoyed getting to think that way
challenging myself to think that way
about patterns and you were able to you
think you were able to take that
proclivity and then apply it to what you
were doing in Humanities and oddly
enough what you ended up doing in the
humanities was producing parodies of of
Humanity's papers and and and so you
found that intellectually compelling
um what what was your what was your
motivation outside of the intellectual
compulsion now you you talked a little
bit about the fact that you were annoyed
about the fact that when you were
teaching at the University you were
called on essentially to falsify the
teaching process so that must be lurking
around in there in the background
somewhere but what were you in pluck
rosenbergosian conspiring about so to
speak when you were producing these
false papers like why the hell were you
doing that because people have hurt no
yeah you're just causing trouble like no
it's a very simple answer we had seen
some of these things because we were
involved in a new atheism movement and
got attacked by this you know woke virus
very early on before anybody knew what
to call it we were all saying third wave
radical feminism back back then that was
the phrase and I think you were the only
person saying something like post-modern
neo-marxism or something like this and
so we were we were looking into this and
we would criticize you know this
deviates from you know standards of you
know free liberal Society this is
oppressive this is against Free Speech
we would offer these criticisms and you
know what we would get back if we didn't
get called White or male or something
stupid we would get the most substantive
criticism we would get is you're not
credentialed you don't have a PhD in
this you can't criticize it so we
thought well you can delegitimize a
fraudulent Enterprise we started to read
the papers and thought that they were
fraudulent and it was an emergency
because they were dipping into the
science yeah well that made you weird to
begin with that you were reading the
papers because I think 80 percent is it
80 percent of humanities papers are are
never cited once somebody's I asked a
question at one point you said this is
sex just what's sexist and I said well
sexism is systemic this feminist woman
was talking to me and I said what does
that mean and she sent me a feminist
Theory paper about feminism about sexism
and I read it and I came back to her and
I said okay I kind of get this concept
but why do you just why don't you say
it's this is systemic sexism and
distinguished from what most people
think of as sexism she said no it is
sexism it's the same thing but they're
clearly not the same thing so this made
me curious what's going on and then I
started to read some of their papers
here and there I wasn't that invested in
it yet it's 2014 and 50. no it also
means it's interesting too it also means
that all these
see I've noticed this this tendency
among creative liberal types
right is that they're very very good at
producing ideas yes but they're not very
good at editing them yes right right and
so and those are actually separate
neurological functions by the way yes so
the two different brain areas do that
and so one's a producer and the other is
an inhibitor an editor and so
if you're in dialogue with someone
true dialogue you produce your ideas but
the other person can act as a Critic
that's what peer review is supposed to
do but if no one's reading your papers
there's no editing function and so that
creativity can just go everywhere and
produce false positives which is what
unconstrained creativity does sure right
it's like well that's a new idea it's
like yeah but it's stupid why is it
stupid because if you act that out in
the world you'll die yes that's like the
definition of stupid it is right right
and you're supposed to kill your stupid
ideas before you act them out and you do
that with critical thinking and if these
papers aren't being read or they're not
being criticized that also means that
the people who are producing the ideas
don't get to hone their ideas right
because they don't get to learn how to
distinguish between the smart ideas and
the and the ideas that aren't so good
right yeah right okay there's no iron to
sharpen the iron whatsoever right right
right right right there's nothing to
separate the wheat from the chaff right
right exactly and there's no Spirit of
dialogue of truly logical inquiry logos
based yeah exactly exactly okay okay so
you are bringing that to Bear makes
sense too because of the discipline that
you came from you're bringing that sharp
eye to bear on this collection of
of what would you call it mixed mixed
creative
overproduction exactly so we thought we
could expose that problem and
simultaneously solve the problem that
our our most annoying critics were
telling us you have no authority to
speak on this because you clearly don't
have a degree in it well we thought well
I'm not going to go to school and go get
a degree why go back to school for The
more I've been in school forever I'm not
doing more school but if we're
publishing at the PHD or the research
level right then surely we know
something about right right right right
well turns out that they did not accept
this as a credential they did not that
did not satisfy them I'm still right
well we can point out for everyone who's
watching and listening to that
you could this is a rule of thumb and
it's a rough one but but it's not so bad
if you're trying to understand this is
what's a PhD equivalent to and
essentially a PhD is equivalent to three
published papers so because in most
universities
um certainly in the social sciences if
you publish three papers in well
reasonably well-regarded journals and
then you aggregate them into a single
document add an introduction and a
discussion you have a PhD that will be
acceptable to your committee right and
so if you can produce three published
papers you have demonstrated by the
standards of the field in fact on on in
the in the fields that are less rigorous
one or even zero published papers will
often do it because lots of times you
know the the median number of
Publications for a PhD graduate is one
yeah immediate right exactly so when you
guys publish three not only have you
mastered the discipline you've exceeded
the norm by a substantial margin sure
right right yeah okay so that's so part
you were trying to indicate I see so
that we were trying to indicate that you
knew that you think the lingo exactly
this is important to criticize we have
this barrier to being able to criticize
it and be taken seriously doing so we
have an authority Gap and a recognized
Authority Gap and a credential Gap and
so let's fill it was the other
motivation this needs to be exposed and
we need to criticize credential
ourselves as authorities that can
criticize this from the outside that was
it because we saw that there were fewer
no authorities on the inside who were
willing to criticize it and so let's
walk me through again why you came to
the conclusion that it needed to be
criticized you touched a little bit on
the fact that you were being attacked
when you put forward the new atheism
arguments by the postmodern horde but
were there other reasons that you felt
that there was like a corruption at the
core of this that needed to be exposed
well we started to read lots of the
papers as a matter of fact a lot of this
these very silly so you started to learn
what was actually happening yes oh
that's nasty yeah and so and then there
was one though that tipped us over the
edge it was actually quite famous it was
operating on a half a million dollars of
a National Science Foundation money it
was a paper that was published in 2016
out of the University of Oregon or four
of the some of the professors anyway
there were four authors or from
University of Oregon and it's about
needing to bring feminism into the
science of glaciology in order to
successfully combat climate change right
right they've got a TED Talk out of this
I mean this is the most I read this
thing and it was so shocking to me as
somebody with a background in science I
actually shut down for psychologically
for almost three days I kind of stayed
in a dimly lit room I wouldn't interact
I barely ate I was so depressed at this
attack on that a journal with this
impact factor so high it was a seven for
those who know what that means would
publish
a paper this off course about what the
Sciences are about I mean it was
suggesting that the Sciences are sexist
once they bring in feminist art projects
it was saying that in addition to
studying and these are true true if I
tell you what's in the paper nobody
believes in addition to studying
satellite photography of glaciers which
are the gods I view from nowhere and
literally called pornographic pictures
because it's you know the the the
satellite is a pornographer staring down
in Mother Earth at cooning at Mother
Earth yes and and I use that g word very
uh intentionally they
went on to say that unless we take
paintings done by women in specific of
glaciers and study those as well beside
the Satellite photographs then it's not
a Comprehensive Science it shuts out all
these other perspectives other means of
knowing if we don't include indigenous
perspectives and mythologies about why
ice is the way that it is and why it
moves then we're we're obviously being
colonialist and masculinist and all
these horrible things and I was shocked
that a high-end not some Fringe goofy
little you know qualitative studies
Journal but a high impact factor Journal
would publish this Brazen of an assault
on the scientific methodology at all I
had no idea how how corrupt it was until
I saw that I see it and then it shocked
you that was I think about it when we
were speaking about that it's an image
that's come to mind a lot lately for me
is that you know the the what we're
seeing is the invasion of whale
carcasses by snow crabs I don't know if
snow crabs is the right word but I think
I know what you mean yeah you bet man
it's like once something stores up value
the universities have stored up value
right historical value right
credentialing value yeah and
unbelievable Financial Resources yes
right they are whale carcasses and so
now everyone On The Fringe is saying you
know I'd like access to that and they
make these arguments about why they
should be included right the Enterprise
because what they're after is access to
those stored resources that's right
exactly that's exactly right so that was
the moment where I I don't think it
shocked you so badly
I think I treated science as sacred oh
yeah well you were part of the new
atheist movement right well this is one
of the things that's so interesting I
think is that and I I don't know what
you make of this exactly but one of the
things I see happening is that so the
enlightenment critique was one of the
reasons for the death of God now and the
new atheist types Dawkins and and Harris
Dawkins in particular would celebrate
the death of God because that would free
the scientific Enterprise from the
superstitious overlay that was
interfering with clear rationality right
but then that begs the question which is
well what is the relationship let's say
between the judeo-christian tradition
and Science and one answer is
antagonistic right and the other is no
the judeo-christian tradition
established the monasteries for example
the universities grow to the monasteries
of the scientific tradition grew out of
the universities and that there's
actually that that the scientific
project is actually embedded in the
judeo-christian project and the reason
for that is the judeo-christian project
is predicated on the Greek idea that
there's a logos in the world and the
Jerusalem idea that there's a logos in
the intellect and all of that's a
precondition for Science and if we lose
God we'll lose science too and I think
that I think that's what's happening I
think that the new atheists because I
think the historical notion that there
is an antagonism between science and
religion is actually a misreading of
History I don't think that is how it
laid itself out and I do believe that
the and it's an oddly postmodern
argument in some ways is that the
scientific Enterprise is embedded in the
broader judeo-christian narrative so
when I look at someone like Dawkins for
example I think okay here's what you
believe Dr dog do you believe there's
logos in the world yes because otherwise
there's that there's an intelligible
order in the world you believe that
studying that intelligible order is
Redemptive right no first you believe
that you are constitute so that you
could understand that yes yes and then
you believe that if you understood that
order that would be Redemptive it's like
every single one of those axioms is
religious that's right that is the
fundamental uh Construction in fact of a
religion it's in fact if we boil it down
into legalese what the Supreme Court
recognizes as what constitutes an
established religion for Establishment
Clause purposes is it a comprehensive
system of of belief and practice that
that this is their definition that
answers fundamental questions about the
world of man's role in it such that it
gives rise to duties of conscience and
this is precisely precisely
you know the legalese kind of practical
version of those same fundamental axioms
because these things there is that
multi-dimensional convergence of of
what's really yeah well it might be you
know that the most fundamental axioms of
a conceptual system are are religious
claims by definition you have to say we
hold these things to be self-evident and
I would say well Dawkins has to hold the
three things that I laid out as
self-evident and I think that those are
part and parcel of the original
judeo-christian argument sure I mean the
fact that the the entire scientific
Enterprise has as hardcore as physics
might be utterly depends on on on a
complete and irrational faith that there
is a logical structure to the world that
doesn't change yeah or that that's
intelligent ways that are intelligent
right because well you could you could
also easily set up as an axiom that it
is immoral to analyze the
transformations of the material world
because all that will produce is danger
and you know the the Frankenstein story
worry the Golem Story the Tower of Babel
story for that matter are variations of
that Axiom that's right look look out be
careful what you study you know you
might open Pandora's Box for example
right have your liver torn out forever
because you're Prometheus and yeah you
know there's certainly you can make a
case for that so the Axiom that
investigating the transformations of the
material world in good spirit let's say
in the proper spirit will be Redemptive
that isn't that isn't a factual
statement right it's a priority claim
yeah okay it's like the Axiom of
infinity is there Infinity who knows but
mathematicians generally accept that
okay we're going to use this concept
Infinity we're going to say there's
Infinity but technically we're going to
see what happens it is unknowable if
there is infinity right right by
definition it's unknowable but there's
an axiom called the Axiom of infinity
infinity exists it more or less is what
it what it states there's a there's a
yeah well I've started to understand
that like that that that the the the
most fundamentally religious and the
most fundamentally axiomatic that's the
same thing sure sure okay and that makes
sense to you that makes complete sense
to me yeah yeah okay so now you go down
the Axiom hierarchy in the farther down
you go the closest you the closer you
get to the sacred essentially and I
think the reason that it's Sacred By the
way so
axioms uh constrain entropy that's a
good way of thinking about it right and
so the reason that you have to hold some
things is sacred is because the things
you hold as sacred are the things that
constrain the most entropy in your
conceptual system so if you blow an
axiom you D you free the entropy that's
what happened to you when you read that
paper yes that's why you're hiding in
that room for three days three days
right right because an axiomatic
presumption had been challenged you
thought Not only was the scientific
Enterprise valued valuable you thought
it was valued yes that's right right
you were wrong I was wrong you bet man
you bet and the stem people are certain
they get to find out how true that is
you know I saw this five years ago I was
warning people and stand by myself you
guys are apolitical
you are sitting ducks you have no idea
what's going to happen when the people
who swarm the humanities and those
people were partly political the
humanities professors so they had some
defense you wait till they land up on
your Shores you people have no idea
what's coming your way they're going to
go through you like a hot knife through
butter and this this is happening look
at our medical journals oh yeah well
they say 75 this is so horrible
um 75 percent of new applicants to stem
positions in the University of
California state systems have their
applications their research dossiers are
unread because their Dei statements
aren't sufficient 75 that's an
astonishing number it is something it is
something to behold boy trophy senko
would smile down on this that's for sure
that's for sure talk about a coup yeah
you know so that you can replace those
Decades of work that it takes to become
say a PhD in something difficult like
mathematics and you can reduce that to a
Dei statement and then you can let the
dimwitsued evaluate Dei statements
decide which mathematicians get to
practice math that's right it's like oh
my God and now the Dei statement will be
written by chat yeah right trick
everybody right right right well maybe
maybe you technical types have come up
with a solution to the Dei problem yeah
just get child GPT to rate the
statements let me do it you've automated
you've automated the compliance process
oh yeah that's pretty damn funny yeah
yeah you know horrible horrible way so
yeah this is this is ultimately what so
why do I feel like I've gotten out of
this resentment well I'm not resentful
okay I feel gratitude I like I began
saying I feel very privileged that I get
to travel and talk yeah so okay so so
let's let's let me unfold what happened
to you you published these papers and
that caused let's walk through that a
little bit that caused all sorts of
trouble right so that was wonderful yeah
okay so so tell us tell me the story and
tell me what's happened in your life
since then because I know now I don't
know you you were a massage therapist
then you wrote These Preposterous papers
and there was an explosion around that
yeah but I have no idea like how you're
keeping Body and Soul together now and
so like what what is your professional
life at the moment and I mean my
professional life now is is is chaos
it's been a learning process to deal
with the amount of travel the demands on
my time the requests and are you being
paid as a speaker constantly and is that
how you're deriving most of your income
most of it yeah so I also created a
company called new discourses where I
publish my own materials and put on my
podcast kind of my own platform right
website Etc right and that is that a
subscription platform new discourse it
has how do you monetize this it's
optional subscription and it's only by
the generosity of other people that it
stays going I don't have any big donors
contrary to what the internet believes
in urban legends I have none zero I
don't think I have a big oil come on big
oils yeah right you end big Pharma no
doubt yeah yeah big Pharma yeah I'm sure
they do yeah I'm sure they do no so but
it's optional I give out virtually
everything for free I offer one product
that's behind a paywall and it's a kind
of more personal podcast where I share
kind of my more Cutting Edge
experimental ideas and stories of from
my trips that I think are instructive in
some way but other than that it's all
public and it's the generosity of of
people who appreciate it are you are you
approximating something that would be
the equivalent of a reasonable academic
salary I'm exceeding that oh well
congratulations rather well right right
well so look at that you started making
the right sacrifices and everything
turned around that's I feel that way
yeah it's not something and again and
how do I feel about it great grateful
I think your answer is a good one by the
way because I was curious serious about
that you know because I've watched
people who were admired in bitterness
say that they're no longer admired in
bitterness and I remember I think it's
the nietzschean dictum which is
something like
um you think you're done with the past
but that doesn't mean the past is done
with you yeah you know and if you've if
you've gone down a dark Road and been in
that for a long time there are traces of
that that last for a long time and they
will come and get you if you think
you've escaped and so but your your
response that you're grateful that's a
good response because gratitude is the
opposite of bitterness I feel like I get
to serve yeah okay that's a good answer
I just do I don't ask for you know you
asked about the speaking fees yeah I
don't ask for very large ones I'm very
modest in what I what I ask you know I
want my expenses covered obviously but
other than do you have an agent I do
okay and it's all very very modest they
keep everything extremely modest because
I I sat down with myself a couple of
years ago and I said if it came to the
fact that let's say this the right
person in the audience because you never
know who yeah yeah and I said no over a
matter of a few hundred or a few
thousand dollars to this event supposing
it would fit into my schedule which is
busy and I said no to this
I've done something Gravely wrong if I
don't have time you know we have to so
what do you use do you have more
invitations than you can fulfill I kind
of hit right at the line sometimes well
because one of them one of the arguments
for raising your face is because it
helps you prioritize if you have a
plethora of invitation correct but
you're right on that I I ride right on
the side and it's wonderful that's a
nice place I'm also grateful for that I
feel like it's just
I'd hesitate to use loaded words
um glibly but it's almost providential
that it's working this way and uh so I'm
very excited about it so I don't feel
like I fell and I can look back on and
reflect
but I think that the moment where the
decision was made was during the
grievance studies papers we wrote one it
was about education we called it the
progressive stack we said we should
Progressive stack the classroom so if
you have we're going to do a privileged
inventory whether I'll make them do that
walk that privilege walk or if you know
you have this or that goes forward three
steps if you're white walk backwards out
of the building or whatever they make
you do then we're going to rank all the
kids and we're going to put you know
your your uh roster for the class will
be ordered according to privilege and
the intersectional privilege correctly
well yes intersection of course and so
and and so the more privilege that you
have the worse we're going to treat you
we're going to ignore you we're going to
our phrasing was invite you to listen
and learn in silence right last week
right and then it progressively got
worse to so to speak you know we'll
speak over you we'll interrupt you we'll
um you know report you for things to the
dean or whatever will actually invite
you to sit in the floor to experience
reparations you should wear chains you
should do humiliation things right for
the other kids staring at you to
overcome your privilege but of course
these are hoaxes so we said
but we'll do it with compassion
critically com compassionate
intellectuals yeah we're dealing with
compassion and the peer reviewers wrote
us back and they said don't use
compassion yeah
Center the needs of the privileged if
you're compassionate with them and
instead they recommended well so they so
because they figured you were on their
side they could show their true colors I
think so right because one of the things
I have learned is that so serpents
camouflage themselves right you know
that we can detect serpent camouflage
better in the bottom half of our visual
field by the way oh yeah yeah yeah you
know what the best camouflage is for
serpents what's that compassion oh sure
sure you bet you bet and it really works
on conservatives and the reason it works
on conservatives is because you can
really make conservatives feel guilty
because they're dutiful so they're guilt
prone yeah so if you can come after
conservatives with compassion and you
can say you're not doing your duty on
the compassionate front instead of the
conservatives going you're a serpent
they go oh no you know we could be a
little better and of course they could
because like who's perfect on that front
of course but yeah well we were talking
just before we started this podcast
about some of the new psychological
research on left-wing authoritarianism
and so I read a paper here a week ago
there's not a lot of papers on this
front there's only about 10 because the
social psychologists denied that
left-wing authoritarianism existed for
seven decades right until 2016. before I
got what would you say disenfranchised
from the University yeah my lab did a
study on left-wing authoritarianism the
first thing we did was to see if there
was a clump of ideas that were
statistically related that you could
describe as both left-wing and
authoritarian and there is and it's
identifiable it's exactly the club of
beliefs you would have been studying and
would suspect yeah we looked at what
predicted that predicted Allegiance with
that set of beliefs low verbal
intelligence negative 0.4 with IQ verbal
IQ so you think well how can people be
you know unwise enough to to believe
these ideas and one of the answers is
while they're not that bright as it
turns out being female having a feminine
temperament right those were the three
big predictors other predictors have
emerged looking at the similar construct
left-wing authoritarianism the best
Victor I've seen is malignant narcissism
correlation is 0.6 0.6 right which is
about as good as the measurement
accuracy of the questionnaires yeah
right so it it it it actually opens up
the question the question is there may
be no difference between left-wing
authoritarianism and malignant
narcissism and what that means is the
serpents are using the language of
compassion to mask their power striving
or simultaneously claiming well of
course we can do this because every
single social relationship in the world
is predicated on nothing but power and
if you don't accept that that just means
that you're a malignant liar that's
right exactly that's normal structure
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then that's that
kind of discourse is disinhibited in the
in the in these disciplines where no one
subjects any of the ideas to critical
evaluation right and the malignant
narcissists are also disinhibited online
yeah right which is a huge problem right
none of our evolved mechanisms for
keeping malignant narcissists under
control are operative on the social
media that's correct yeah
they can do whatever they want they have
100 free reign 30 percent of internet
traffic is pornographic right
criminality is absolutely Rife on the
internet right you can't control it and
then you have the subclinical
criminality which are the troll demon
types yeah yeah and they're monetized by
the social media platforms of course
I've been trying to convince
well convinced I've made a case on
social media multiple times that
platforms like Twitter for example
should separate the anonymous people
from the real people they should put
them in different categories right
because if you can't bear responsibility
for your words you shouldn't be allowed
free reign in the in the in the realm of
discourse and the reason for that people
say well anonymity protects Freedom it's
like no if you took a hundred Anonymous
troll demons one of them is a
whistleblower and the other 99 are
malignant narcissists so and I think
they should be allowed to have their say
but they shouldn't be thrown the troll
demons and those are what would you say
machine human hybrids right because when
you're online you're a machine human
troll demons are not human
right Anonymous troll demons are not
human right you don't put them in with
the people you put them in like
Anonymous troll demon hell and if you
want to go there and visit and see what
they're up to no problem but they
shouldn't be confused with people who
will take the consequences of their
words onto themselves you haven't
operated anonymously no I have not why
not they have
you just gotta say these things I I you
just have to say these things why do you
think that I think that telling the
truth is the most important thing that
we have to do so why don't you why not
Shield that with anonymity
that's not
as Grave how on how on Earth can someone
come and challenge me or check me if I'm
if I'm Anonymous I can just vanish right
right right so what I come and see I
don't have to subject any of your ideas
to critical evaluation or to take any of
the weight of what you say on yourself
right or compare it against a pattern of
established thought uh
I like the idea that I I do understand
why some people have certain risks
they're not willing to take but I've
been trying to encourage them to take
those risks understand it's like yeah
yeah yeah if you have something to say
story of Jonah let me I'll give you a
one minute summary the story of Jonah
okay so Jonah is just minding his own
business God comes along says you know
that City Nineveh
yeah
well those people have deviated from the
straight narrow and I'm not very happy
and I'm going to wipe them out but I'd
like you to go there and tell them what
they're doing wrong
um and let them know that they're in
danger and Jonah thinks there's no
bloody way I'm going to a city of 120
000 people to tell them that they're
wrong no so he hops on the boat and goes
to hell the other direction well then
the waves rise and the winds blow and
this and the ship is threatened right
yeah which means that if you don't say
what you're called upon to say then the
ship is threatened well the sailors
think well there's someone on board who
hasn't who's uh on outs with God because
that's why the storms are rising so they
go talk to everybody on board
you've got a problem with God and
Jonathan says well as a matter of fact
yeah I've just disobeyed a direct order
and those sailors say well we got to
throw you overboard because like
otherwise we're all going to die
right so that means if you hold your
tongue when you're called upon to speak
then everyone dies so off they throw up
right now he's drowning and you think
well that's pretty bad he's drowning and
and then that's not so bad because the
next thing that happens is a horrible
Creature from the darkest part of the
Abyss comes up and swallows him and
takes him down to the bottom and so what
that means is that if you hold your
tongue when you're called upon to speak
not only do you put the ship at risk and
then lightly drown but then something
will happen to you that will make you
wish you drown right so Jonah's now in
hell right which is where you go when
you hold your tongue when you have
something to say and he's there for
three days in hell and then he repents
the whale spits him up on shore
then he goes to Nineveh and says
I know what I'm talking about you guys
you've gone somewhere dark you better
get your act together they put on sock
cloth and Ashes and repent and God
decides not to destroy them and that
isn't precisely where the story ends but
that's where that party ends yeah yeah
hold your tongue at your apparel you
know and I knew that because people have
talked to me and maybe they've said the
same thing to you they said well you
know thank you for your bravery and I
think it's not bravery I know what to be
afraid of and I'm nowhere near afraid as
afraid of the people who would want to
compel my language as I am afraid of the
consequences of not saying what I have
to say yeah right the ship sinks you
drown and then you wish you would have
drowned yeah right yeah yeah I feel that
I feel that that's exactly I
I see the I see what to be afraid of
well you know and that's what this
totalitarian state everybody holds their
tongue and that's that's this turning
point that I was telling you about
because I'm I'm getting this feedback
from these peer reviewers that have now
pulled this mask off of themselves no
compassion we're gonna abuse interesting
students out of privilege which we had
meant college students but this could
apply to Children Of course Very quickly
and faster because they have no they
have no defensive voice look what we did
with them with masks yeah so we're going
to abuse them and there'll be no
compassion we're gonna use What's called
the pedagogy of discomfort they told us
horrible wow and and so so you really
saw the narcissists unmasked in the peer
review process I talked with uh Mike
Naina who was doing a documentary it
recently came out the reformers it's
called Uh documenting what we were doing
and I called him and I said Mike you
gotta we gotta talk about this we get
talking about that feedback I sent it to
him and we decided that the phrase we
used and I've got so much trouble for
this online it was that it represents
the seed of a genocide I don't know if
the seed's going in the ground I don't
know if it's going to sprout I know if
it's going to grow I don't know if the
tree is going to bear fruit you're
actually accurate about that you know I
I wrote a paper with one of my students
who had gone to visit the mass grave
sites in Eastern Europe by the way
before she became one of my students
brilliant girl uh Maya chicken uh what
was her name we wrote a paper on the
precursors to genocide and uh enhanced
victimization
the enhancement of the sense of
victimization is that one of the steps
along the pathway to genocide yeah so
get them before they get us for example
so I stare this in the face this road if
followed to its apparent potential
conclusion is a genocide you know that's
or totalitarian or and so I I thought
about this I sat on this for a couple of
weeks and I took one of the braver
moments of my life I went to my wife and
I said can I quit my job and dedicate my
life to it this was the massage therapy
job yeah no more can I dedicate all of
my time to studying this and telling the
world about it as fast as I can learn
about it and she being a woman of great
practicality and wisdom said can you
make money doing that right and I said I
don't know it's actually a good question
right because I mean it is one way of
Market testing the viability of your
ideas sure because one of the things you
might assume is that if there's no
Market what makes you think you have
anything to offer yeah exactly right
right and so so good discipline she gave
me a Runway she's like you have 18
months to figure that out and if we get
to the end of 18 months she's a woman so
18 months is 15 months in reality so we
got about to month number 15 and it got
a little Rocky and then I was actually
these like I said I'm completely crowd
supported other than the speaking fees
and so I because you're actually an
autonomous intellectual correct right
right right I built it that way it's
very intentional it's a very difficult
thing to attain so very intentionally so
that nobody can tell me I have to show
right right right right and because
things have to be said and I don't know
what has to be said but I can't be told
to shut up when I have to say it and
yeah I can't have anybody some think
tank guy looking over my shoulder saying
just don't go there don't insult so and
so we're not going to drag that into the
light I I can't have any of that and so
I wrote myself a salary check at month
number 16. yeah that was the whopping
total for 16 months of effort to try to
build the beginnings of two thousand
dollars this is my big oil money two
thousand dollars is not zero it's not
zero and getting
getting from zero to one is really
really really hard once you get to two
thousand dollars the next two thousand
is a lot easier zero is rough man people
yeah zero is a black hole it's not like
any other number it's a black hole it's
really hard to escape it's true you
multiply any number by zero what do you
get zero right right exactly that's
right zero devours everything and
getting out of zero is really really
difficult but once you get out of zero
you can start moving forward essentially
that's the Pareto distribution issue
yeah yeah so so you made some money
right so you saw that there was a market
there was a market I was doing something
useful I was doing something right uh I
very fortuitously chose among this you
know we'd written cynical theories that
hadn't published yet and so I have this
Pantheon of of evils to choose from what
do I fo there's two you can't focus what
a deal the Ultimate Buffet in hell yeah
exactly and I I chose just kind of
finger on the ground or ear to the
ground I guess is the metaphor I mix my
metaphors the critical race Theory would
be the most accessible and relevant to
start exposing first so I dove into that
full blast full bore and I've
fortunately created a library of
decoding critical race theory in advance
of George Floyd dying
for the preceding eight months was that
video mostly like what no it was mostly
writing but what was mostly writing the
blog no uh I created the website some of
those articles are blog type articles
and some of them are explanatory but
what I found I thought would be most
important and this goes back to that
mathematical comment I made earlier
about the definitions was I knew they
were misusing words and so I started to
create a lexicon I started to create an
encyclopedia of their terminology and I
just would focus on one term after
another let me get into their head and
know what they mean and go read primary
sources when they use the word democracy
where does this come oh my gosh we're
all the way back to Lenin you know Lenin
you feel do you feel that you're dealing
with a they or do you you know there's
this there's this biblical idea that
what we wore against is principalities
and I think of a principality one
variant of a principality is a system of
ideas yeah and I think well there's
there's no in a way there's no they
there's this there's a system of ideas
that's an animated that's a set of
animating principles sure right and it
partially inhabits a multitude of people
well but I think there are there are two
answers to this there's a very diffuse
they if we say the woke we generally
know that we're speaking about people
who think in certain ways that they've
adopted some of this power analysis but
it's very diffuse and maybe it's only a
small amount maybe it's a great amount
maybe yeah right but then there are the
people who pay for it and I mean with
large sums of money they're a very
distinct they somebody has decided to
pour the gasoline into this fire and
they decided do you think but do you
think that they have any sense they
again
these people I think they know exactly
what they're doing with it they are
disrupting Western civilizations so that
they can recolonize it with their own
position
and this is why I get called a
conspiracy theorist online despite the
fact that they basically write this in
their books themselves and who okay for
you who who are the primary actors in
that they well there's a front that I
would I usually typically name that is
obviously the people that are the public
face of this okay and these are people
at the world economic foreign
book that he wrote well it says fourth
really but the second book he wrote in
that series is much more poignant but
the way that he writes is it's you know
maybe 130 pages of a book or I don't
know it's not that long and it's
business cliche business cliche business
terrifying pair of paragraphs business
cliche and so there's a there's a yeah
so if you read it in in in regards to
the fact that the the the meat it's a
lot of fun and a very little Burger his
camouflage is managers man
right right well I did notice too that a
lot of the things I saw at universities
that were really deep falsehoods weren't
compassion they were managers speak
managers speak that's right yeah manager
speaking if you read something we made
those together it was probably designed
to put you to sleep so you don't see
yeah managers speak is what people on
the administrative front who have
absolutely no ability cloaked themselves
in so they look competent that's right
that's exactly right oh yeah so here's
the email in the in the middle almost
squarely in the middle of the great
narrative for a better future which is
the follow-up book to the great reset
it's called narrative for a better
future the the great narrative for a
better future yeah you can't make this
up and so right in the middle he has a
set of paragraphs it's maybe five
paragraphs but it covers three ideas and
number one we're going to force all of
the corporations to adopt ESG standards
and we're going to do that through top
down manipulations as a public-private
partnership governments and big business
working together fascism in other words
fascism
with the ngos being the coordinating
entity so the world economic forum is a
is a hub that connects these things
which means there's something probably
behind it that's a different they that's
really that's the Legion by the way yes
and then so secondly we're going to
transform the youth to demand ESG they
won't work in a company they won't buy
from a company et cetera unless they're
ESG compliant we're going to change the
youth culture then third we're going to
rewrite the social contract
to accept this new only those three
things only those three things very
nefarious though and he repeats he's got
the uniform for it Independence command
the accent yeah well the central cast
Central Casting that's right he needs a
crow on his shoulder yeah yeah or a bald
cat to pet yeah right exactly yeah so
yeah so he he says a speech earlier this
year an interview he says that we're
going to rewrite the social contract he
says this again and again but he says
specifically this time we're going to
rewrite the social contract so that
Society accepts as we move from an
economy of production and consumption to
an economy and I kid you not Jordan
of caring and sharing oh yeah and that's
communist I mean because productive
generosity on the free market front
hasn't worked correct right right
because it hasn't lifted more people out
of poverty since the year 2000 than
drifted out of poverty in the entire
some history of humanity before that
yeah but climate change yeah I know
exactly yeah yeah yeah yeah so this is
you know it's so interesting eh that
like I I've got a couple here's some
tell me what you think about these ideas
so so so
tyrants use fear to produce compulsion
they're after compulsion they want to
aggregate the power and so they'll use
fear and apocalyptic fear is the best
sort of fear to use of course right and
so so now you can tell the tyrants
because everybody wants to know who's
listening how do you tell the tyrants
from the real leaders okay the tyrants
will frighten you into compulsion and
they'll and they'll use they'll they'll
use the crisis and the catastrophe to
justify the compulsion and you might say
well there's a real crisis and the right
answer to that is there's always an
apocalyptic crisis that's right that's a
that's a universal Eternal truth we and
it's partly because all of us die it's
partly not because you die and I die but
also because every single person we know
our whole culture everything we know
will die yeah so the apocalypse is
always there and sometimes that happens
dramatically and sometimes it happens
incrementally
but it happens and so we're always
facing apocalyptic crises because of
that and then you say well in spite of
that you can have a form of government
that's not a tyranny well not if you use
the fear of the apocalyptic crisis to
compel and to aggregate power and so any
leader who tells you that the crisis is
so intense that it necessitates
emergency compulsion that's a tyrant
that's exactly right and then there's
another corollary to that which is
imagine you're tyrannical and you are
genuinely frightened by this crisis then
I would say
your nervous system as indicated by the
paralysis of your fear that you're too
small a night for that Dragon right and
so you shouldn't be parading yourself
around as a leader it's like no you're a
frightened Tyrant because you're not a
leader and we can tell you're not a
leader
because you're a frightened Tyrant right
if you were a leader even in the face of
a crisis you would keep your head that's
right and you wouldn't use compulsion
that's right so all these apocalyptic
nightmare mongers who are saying well
well we're going to burn up the planet
it's like yeah that and 10 other
apocalypses by the way that doesn't mean
you get to centralize all the power and
take it for yourself and use compulsion
this like I really started to understand
that as far as I was concerned I was at
War when I saw that the leftist radical
narcissistic malignant types were
willing to sacrifice the poor to their
climate scam that's right right so well
let's crank up Energy prices well why
well because Renewables because climate
it's like do you know who you're going
to hurt with high energy costs
you're going to destroy the marginal
right because all you have to do is
energy and food there's no bloody
difference those people are barely
Clinging On to the edge of reality you
crank up Energy prices 10 you wipe out
like 20 million people yeah it's like
well that's okay sir because you know
there are too many people on the planet
anyways it's like yeah I know who's
speaking in that voice exactly you bet
right the great Cosmic Joker yeah yeah
there's too many people on the planet
yeah I watch people actually say that I
think do you know who's speaking out of
your mouth
God
stunning so you know what the great
narrative is for a better future he
accepts he says it explicitly this is
closer to the end of the book he in one
paragraph says what the great narrative
is after he makes his case with you saw
the punch line is centralization of
power transformation of the universe or
whatever
the great narrative is we Face multiple
existential crises climate change
pandemics exactly The Four Horsemen
we've faced multiple existential credit
the poly crisis they call it yeah yeah
therefore we need greater Global
cooperation cooperation which of course
is going to have to be managed by
assistance down that road real fast yeah
700 million cctvs right and gate
recognition oh such fun right smile for
the government I saw a video that said
it showed the guy scan his face to go
through the gate and it didn't let him
it didn't open and it said in Chinese it
says I don't read Chinese but it was
translated smile for so I assume it's
true smile for the government and he
smiled and it opened could you imagine
yes well if I'd been in airports I can
imagine yeah well yes I hate in my
pocket now is my passport from the last
time I went to China I keep a little
slip of paper they gave after they took
all my fingerprints my handprints and
scanned my eyes just to go through
immigration the last time I went to
Beijing in 2019. so I carry it's
completely faded you know it's a heat
transfer so the Drone is coming your way
buddy exactly yeah the gate recognition
drone nice poison dart for you yeah
exactly this is this is very scary but
that's it there's very Tyrant though
we're building the good Skynet it's like
really yeah building the good stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah wow and so the ESG openly
is there to serve the Rock and Larry
Fame BlackRock and the United Nations
yeah evil Central because they're set up
to establish the the reign of the 17
sustainable development goals of what
they call agenda 23. I helped write
those goddamn things you know oh no and
I gotta tell you too we we worked on
that document back in 2012. you know why
there are 17 of them I'm relentlessly
curious about it no no I don't know when
when we wrote when we helped write the
document there were like 170 and one of
the criticisms that I kept living is
like hey guys guess what you can't have
170 priorities right you can have one
priority because that's what makes it a
priority and I try to find out why there
were 170 and the answer was well there's
170 different constituents to please and
we don't want to offend anyone it's like
Oh you mean you don't want to do
anything
it's like well yeah that is you know
wait wait no no that's what we mean but
we don't usually say that sure of course
right and that I would say in my defense
such as it is that if you think the
document that was produced in 2012 was
bad you should have seen what it was
like before it got edited wow right wow
yeah right right well one of the things
I did realize after going through that
process was that well apart from the
fact that it was Preposterous to have
170 goals that no one had rank ordered
the goals in any halfways intelligent
way there was no cost benefit analysis
and then Bjorn lomberg's team started to
do that right right Bjorn wrote a book a
while back called how to spend 75
billion dollars to make the world a
better place which is an intelligent
approach to I wouldn't say the poly
crisis because that isn't how he frames
it but you know if we were actually
going to try to lift the help lift the
remaining people in abject poverty out
of poverty laurenburg has shown that
there are ways that sure far less
expensive than the trillions of dollars
that we will waste not not fixing the
climate just like they've not fixed the
climate in Germany right Germany what
catastrophe the bloody and energy costs
are now five times as high five times as
high unreliable dependent on potent and
other dictators around the world right
and they're burning late night so per
unit of energy they actually produce
more pollution than they did before they
started the Green Revolution right and
they're and their response to that
criticism is we have to do stupid things
we have to do stupid virtue signaling
destructive things faster yeah exactly
right God yeah stunning net zero that's
right zero for you but you've seen the
absolute zero as well that's beyond Net
Zero that this is a is a project a think
tank project that would come out in 2019
from UK fires f-i-r-e-s which is a
conglomeration of the British government
and the Cambridge and Oxford and
University College London or whatever
that's called and
all of this
lays out the idea that and of course
this is just the Overton window
stretching we should take it seriously
but it's probably not what will happen
yeah right but they argue that Net Zero
is not nearly enough we must have
absolute zero an absolute zero they're
saying what they mean absolute zero
emissions
absolutely well they openly in the
documents say people should start buying
warmer clothing now especially old
people you know but you know they're
cluttering up the emergency room no air
travel I know I know you know short haul
flight say yeah two weeks ago between
any two cities that were connected by
rail I know the absolute plan is well
this is what I said Net Zero means all
you peasants who are watching and
listening you should pay attention to
this Net Zero means zero for you that's
what it means and buy Plan you little
people you don't need cars God who needs
a private automobile I knew 15 years ago
that the bloody totalitarians would go
after the cars sure because nothing
screams Freedom like a 350 horsepower
Mustang in the hands of a 16 year old
boy it's like no we got to clamp down on
that that's right he can go wherever he
wants and do whatever he wants you know
cluttering up the planet and producing
carbon yeah so it's like no cars right
the goal is 90 reduction in private
automobile uh ownership you think well
you get to have an electric car it's
like no the grid can't sustain electric
charging well how we deal with that how
about you peasants don't get to have
cars that's right right no cars no
flights no meat no heat no air
conditioning no container shipping oh
yeah well who needs who needs who needs
Goods so we go back to our Neo Marxist
Herbert marcusa writing in 64 and
one-dimensional man and what is he
saying it was his argument he says well
the problem with socialism is they can't
produce the problem with capitalism is
it's not sustainable it over produces
and ends up so we need unsustainable
non-production correct right right
that's the Socialist solution and so
what we have the best how about we have
the worst of Both Worlds yeah and so he
says what do we have to do we have to
start getting used to less lower
standards of living gadgets
right right right right
all the people who will be getting us
used to lower standards of living will
be flying around in their private jets
deciding how to do that eating steak
that's right of course of course oh yeah
so you are a conspiracy theorist
fundamentally well I mean I I
fundamentally reject the word theorist I
don't think it's a theory uh I think
that they're they're open about their
collaboration and so yeah well that's so
interesting because we have antifa right
and at the same time we have actual
Fascism and everything that antifa
attacks has nothing to do with the
actual fascism that's right yeah so it's
so there's another great Cosmic joke for
you yeah the anti-fascists are
supporting a gigantic conglomeration of
governments and large Banks and
industries for all working companies
Legacy Media isn't that fantastic yeah
it's really it's really it's really
Cosmic jokes are piling up yeah well
I've been posting pictures of evil
clowns lately and people think they're
wondering what the hell I'm up to you
know which form of insanity has now
gripped me like I realized that Satan is
an evil clown right I started to
understand that you know when when I
when I encountered the sign that was
over Auschwitz because the sign that was
over Auschwitz was Arabic mecht Frey
yeah which means work will make you free
right it's like a thought that's a joke
then I thought who would tell a joke in
Auschwitz right well yeah but who's the
who's the spirit behind himler right
who's the great Cosmic Joker and then
also uh Mutual assured destruction right
the acronym for years was mad I thought
oh that's a joke too right right it's
all these jokes you know and then I
watched the death of Stalin have you
seen that no oh it's great it's a movie
about I've heard about oh it's so great
because it's it's as Bru it it portrays
the brutal reality of the Soviet Union
there are terrible murderous raping
catastrophic things going on in the
background of the movie Non-Stop and
then there's these five Jokers one of
whom is stellen and the rest of his evil
crew and they are like they're bumbling
parodies right everything's a parody and
I realized after really thinking about
that and thinking about that motif of
the Joker and the and the clown which
has become so prevalent in modern
culture I thought I CC When Things
become totalitarian they turn into a
parody right like Dylan Mulvaney is a
parody and what's happening to women's
sports is a parody and what North Face
is doing with their advertising is a
parody and it's like oh yes that's right
Satan is an evil clown yeah right what
did Marcus write in 69 so he wrote in
essence Liberation that it's crucial
that the resistance meaning them the
radicals take on the form he said that's
the clownish forms they so irritate the
establishment it must become an
antinomian Revolution right everything
upside down everything upside down
everything everything becomes and then
so Judith Butler talks about the
politics of parody you give this kind of
Despair we'll never know any of that
happen oh yeah politics strategy yeah
politics a parody of the clownish forms
that the that irritate the establishment
I remember reading this because of
course clown world is the meme on the
internet they call it yeah yeah and I'm
reading Marcus and I stumbled on this
taking on the clownish forms it's like
oh my God clown world was a plan right
the only thing about the evil clowns is
they're not funny like that's the people
that's funny no they're not funny that's
right they're not funny at all it's not
funny at all right and so and and that's
quite interesting too because one of the
things you see about the totalitarian
left is they really hate comedians they
right so they love parody but they hate
comedy that's right right and it's got
to be it's got to be parody of the
darkest form yeah it's always dark or
just almost intentionally stupid or
destructive yeah every time every time
grotesque frequently grotesque yeah
frequently monstrous yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it's never fun okay so how do you know
you're not just crazy
um I asked myself that a lot too and I
don't know that I have a really great
answer for that is your wife sane she
seems to be pretty sane she's very
grounded okay well that's helpful and
she still likes you she's she very much
likes me and she's very convinced that
I'm not crazy so okay and she is
right you could both be crazy do you
have friends
it's a few yeah
are they sane some of them some of them
not maybe I don't know uh it's a weird
weird world we occupy but yeah most of
them are most of them are well that's
one of the ways you can check right is
you want to have people around you
especially if you're playing in this in
this abysmal realm let's say you bloody
well want to have people around you who
will give you the straight story you'll
get demented and bent out of shape you
know what it need to say about the abyss
right you stare into it and it stares
back that's right that's right right and
if you fight with monstrous forms you
have to be very careful that you don't
become monstrous yourself right and I
don't think you can do that yourself I
think you have to have people around you
are going tapping the industry hey hey
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah keep the
humility up and the Gratitude well
humility is absolutely Central this has
become this is this has become kind of
my main issue I speak often with you
know Christian audiences but also
political audiences and it just what
unites this the the this kind of broadly
secular resistance and then the to the
woke and then the very religious and it
the truly religious are humble before
God and the rest of the religious are
prideful right true right you know the
Canadian government announced Pride
season yeah yeah because you know pride
pride parade isn't enough Pride day
isn't it yeah Pride week well that's not
enough
either Pride season Pride all year yeah
yeah yeah yeah I see it's so interesting
to see the worship of Pride it's like
well that is what we need it's like yeah
I think that's what you mean it looks
like that's what you say or the words
that's what the words you say mean God
only knows what you mean you might not
mean anything but the words you say mean
something just like Equity means
something and hey we're going over to
the Daily wire plus side now so if
you're interested in that head over
there give some consideration to
supporting them if you like what they're
doing
and yeah well thanks again James very
good talking with you
hello everyone I would encourage you to
continue listening to my conversation
with my guest on dailywireplus.com